in paris the festive displays are
grabbing the eye but so are french
covered 19 rates a month before
christmas it's beginning to look a lot
like late august the last time the
number of weekly new cases went past two
hundred per hundred thousand people
today we're announcing 30 000 covert
cases over the last 24 hours it's a
major increase in infections that shows
if it was needed in any way that we are
indeed in the midst of a fifth wave of
the pandemic
vehement's urging people to get
vaccinated and have booster shots across
the european union 67.7 per cent of the
population is fully vaccinated but rates
vary widely between countries and the
world health organization says there's
growing evidence protection against
infection and mild disease is declining
it wants a vaccine plus approach
combining vaccinations with measures
such as face mask wearing claiming more
than 160 000 lives could be saved if
mass coverage of 95 was achieved
daily covered related deaths across the
eu have reached nearly 4 200 nearly
double the level two months ago
in germany the latest 24-hour figure was
335 deaths and new infections are at a
record high at nearly 67 000.
the who is warning that by march
there'll be high or extreme stress in
intensive care units in almost all the
53 countries that comprise its europe
region at this hospital near cologne
like in many places covered patients
needing intensive care are mainly
younger unvaccinated people
we've increasingly got younger people in
intensive care the amount of time
they're treated is significantly longer
and it blocks intensive care beds for a
longer period which are then not
available for the care of other patients
some german politicians are now
advocating compulsory vaccination at
least for specific professions austria
has already announced covid jabs will be
compulsory for everyone from february
and the country's just returned to a
full national lockdown the measures have
seen a large increase in demand at the
largest vaccination center here in
vienna
meanwhile as cases rise sharply in the
netherlands they've started transferring
coronavirus patients to germany to ease
pressure on dutch hospitals nadine
barber al jazeera